ما يهمني هو أن أربعة أيام قد مرت
وأطفالنا هناك ما يهمني
العالم، أي نوع من العالم، أي نوع من العالم الذي تفعله؟
حرب على ظهور أطفالنا
[موسيقى]
وعلى حلس أن يعترف بصدق بألمه وحزنه
لقد خذلتنا قيادة الدولة والجهاز الأمني
لقد فشلنا في البقاء آمنين
[موسيقى]
المدنيين
ل
إكسب إلى إيمي
imi
أدعو وأتوسل إلى حماس لاجيد أن تتوجه إلى القلب
لك لأنك إنسان، لديك قلب، أنت ابني
أنوش تواصل هناك واحفظني آمنًا
الأطفال والأب والأم والرجال والنساء
ولجميع المواطنين المتواجدين هناك
جريمة
[موسيقى]
اشتروا قطاع غزة إذا لم تفعل هذه الحكومة ذلك
تغلب على نفسك، ستكون هناك أزمة ثقة كبيرة أخرى هنا
نحن ذاهبون لتطهير مدينة في سلسلة إسرائيل لا أفعل ذلك
أتذكر حالة قمنا فيها بإخلاء مدينة في إسرائيل
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
نيوت غزال بالفعل، ويبدو أن اتجاه الغزال واضح
أننا نذهب إليه ولكني لم أسمع كلمة واحدة
من هذه الحكومة على بعض خطة التحرير
أنا مختطف كلما تحدثوا عن منطقة غزة
تقول لطيف، فأين رومي، أين كل الأطفال الآخرين
أين عفير أين كل الأطفال؟
من الآخرين